growing up I love the space
program
but nobody doing that stuff look like
me very few people today even have a
clue about black people's contribution
to human space flag that was the only
black Arrow space the only black Nas
black first black
as because they weren't written in
history
books
in the early days of the Civil Rights
Movement NASA wanted to show that they
were engaged in equality for all I was
told by friends and enemies alike you're
20 years too soon Buddy if you qualify
and would like to be an astronaut now is
the time this is your NASA I don't think
America or anybody knew that was a body
in a
way it was imaginary it was a lie around
the same time there was a Cuban who was
the first first person of color to fly
the Soviets made that
history not the United
States to see a black man in space 2 1
it would have changed
things three of us all recognize that
one of us would be the first black
astronaut I would have made it to the
Moon
they were not going to let that
happen representation becomes critically
important to help us keep moving down
that
path back in the day they were saying
that black are too ignorant to be flying
in space I'm smitten to you're up there
doing all these wonderful things black
history is American
history we forget it at our
peril